in joining us Aaron Studios is
syndicated columnist Mota cheran good
Sunday morning thanks very much for
being with us we have to talk about CPAC
I know we chatted on radio this past
week for c-span radio but you were in on
the dais at National Harbor in Baltimore
just outside of Washington DC National
Harbor Maryland you were booed by the
audience what happened well I felt that
it was necessary to say a few simple
truths about our president about the
things that the Republican Party has
done and about some of the decisions
that CPAC made that I think are very
dangerous because they're moving CPAC
which is a very prominent conservative
organization in the direction of the
Nationalists all right european-style
politics and I was particularly outraged
by their invitation to Marion lepen who
is the granddaughter of John Murray
lepen you were asked questions about the
me2 movement mm-hmm and you said what I
said that it is you know while my fellow
panelists and I certainly agreed on many
things about where feminism has gone
wrong and many other issues I said that
it was paper critical on our part to
discuss this whole question of sexual
harassment and sexual assault and so on
without acknowledging their major
figures in our party including a
president who have been accused of
atrocious behavior toward women and who
not only have been accused but who
acknowledge it I mean presidents boasted
about basically grabbing women against
their consent and keep having multiple
extramarital affairs and so on you know
it's just that the list is very very
long moreover this party with the
president's leadership endorsed for the
United States Senate Roy Moore who was
incredibly accused child molester taking
us beyond any sort of barriers of what
was considered decent and honorable
behavior in politics and until we
Republican women stand up and shout
about that we're not going to have any
credibility when we're discussing the
meat
to movement did you intend to bring that
up before the panel began yes so let's
show her audience we covered it in its
entirety for the c-span networks here's
an excerpt from the CPAC conference
National Harbor Maryland outside of
Washington DC what gets you riled up so
I agree with everything my fellow
panelists have said and I could say that
the misuse of data like you know the
so-called 77 cents on the dollar figure
which is a statistic that's impossible
to kill even though it's false but I'm
actually gonna twist this around a bit
and say that I'm disappointed in people
on our side okay for being hypocrites
about sexual harasser z' and abusers of
women or in our party who are sitting in
the White House who brag about their
extramarital affairs who brag about
mistreating women and because he happens
to have an hour after his name we we
look the other way
we don't complain this is this is a
party that was ready to endorse the
Republican party endorsed Roy Moore for
the Senate in the state of Alabama even
though he was a credibly accused child
molester you cannot claim that you stand
for women and and put up with that
well you don't and you wrote about this
I'm glad I got booed at CPAC as a way of
history we should point out that this
was the conference this serve as the
launching pad for Ronald Reagan correct
I believe so among many other things but
yes and look CPAC has a little bit of a
checkered history sometimes they've been
mainstream sometimes they've been a
little kooky but as I said in my piece
you know in the past the ways that
they've been unconventional have been
things like you know hosting conferences
about whether the flat tax is the way to
go or whether all taxation is theft you
know that kind of thing but last year
they invited Milo I innopolis some maybe
mispronouncing his last name who is
nothing but an all the right product
Probab provocateur is the word I was
looking for thank you Steve who you know
thinks it's amusing to just to praise
the alt-right who thinks it's funny to
have to be singing and have people do
the nazi salute at a bar and who's I
guess an advocate for some kind of
pedophilia or so there's some other term
for when it's not quite pedophilia but
older men having sex with teenage boys
and he's all for that and that's the
sort of thing that CPAC has descended to
and I think this is a little bit so part
of it is just just bad judgment part of
it is also the triumph of the
entertainment aspect of conservatism
over substance so they want clicks they
want attention they want to be
outrageous they want to create liberal
tears and in doing and chasing all that
they've they've shown that they are
willing to throw away all standards
about what is decent in politics and so
the invitation to Milo the invitation
sheriff Clark is also a very
disreputable figure he was lionized at
the CPAC conference and and of course
Marion lepen is a National Front
member
in in France and she thinks that her
grandfather who is a racist anti-semite
nationalists all right type she thinks
that he is a visionary and that he's
been more right than wrong and so forth
and so to have her presented by match
lap who's the head of CPAC as a what do
you call it either a a classical liberal
he called her she's the exact opposite
she is the exact opposite we are talking
with Mona chair and she is also a senior
fellow at the ethics and Public Policy
Center syndicated columnist I want to
bring a couple of issues on the table to
get your reaction and then get to your
phone calls this is from the front page
of the New York Times
Muller's focus signaling a widening of
the Russia inquiry and new reporting
from Maggie Haberman and Mark Mazzetti
of the New York Times reads as follows
Georg nadir a Lebanese American
businessman has hovered on the fringes
of international diplomacy for three
decades mr. Nader is now a focus of the
investigation by special counsel robert
muller in recent weeks mr. Muller's
investigators have questioned mr. nadir
and have pressed witnesses for
information about any possible attempts
by the united arab emirates to buy
political influence by directing money
to support mr. Trump during the
presidential campaign the New York Times
goes on to write the investigators have
also asked about mr. Nader's role in
White House policymaking suggesting that
the Special Counsel investigation has
broadened beyond Russia election
meddling to include the United Arab
Emirates influence on the Trump
administration or potential influence
the focus on mr. Nader could also prompt
an examination of how money from
multiple countries has flowed through
and influenced Washington during the
Trump era so what we have now is some
radical non transparency from this
administration and honestly the voters
accepted this they when Donald Trump was
asked to reveal his tax returns disclose
them he at first promised that he would
and he said they'd be beautiful and so
on and it and then he gave a variety of
different excuses for not doing so all
right in the end he didn't do it and the
voters accepted that so now we have this
black box
what goes on in the financial dealings
of the administration we don't know
whether there are all kinds of
influences it's certainly possible it
has but it's important to say it's not
proved but it is something that is
worrisome and that maybe we will learn
our lessons after this about the
importance of knowing quite a bit more
about the finances of any person who
puts himself forward or herself as
president I should hasten to add that
Hillary Clinton was not exactly as pure
as the driven snow in her finances
either and all the confusion about the
Clinton Foundation your colleague Pete
Waner at the ethics in public policy
center has a piece it's available this
morning in the New York Times opinion
page the white house is a black hole and
you can read it online at nytimes.com
next to that is the front page below the
fold the reporting of actually Parker
Phil Rucker and Josh Tosi of the near of
The Washington Post
aides see a president isolated and on
edge they write the following quote
inside the White House aides over the
past week have described an era of
anxiety and volatility with an
uncontrollable commander in chief at its
center these are the darkest days in at
least a half a year they say and they
worried just how much further President
Trump and his administration may plunge
into unrest and malaise before they
start to recover as one official put it
we haven't bottomed out Trump is now a
president in transition at times angry
and increasingly isolated he fumes in
private that just about every time he
looks up on a television screen the
cable news headlines are trumpeting yet
another scandal his voice frustration he
voices frustration that his son-in-law
Jared Kushner has few on-air defenders
he revives old grudges and he confides
to friends that he is uncertain about
whom to trust so one way to see this
administration is as a long-running
reality show where the president has a
very keen appreciation for drama and for
the public's
attention span and he's a kind of a
genius at changing the subject or
creating a new controversy to cover up
yesterday's controversy and so you know
I've seen reports like this before you
know there's so much chaos how can this
possibly continue and basically it has
continued thirteen months though there
was a period of calm for a few months
when Kelly first took over but now we
seem to be returning to the kind of you
know mayhem that characterized the first
few months of the president's
administration and honestly you have to
think if there is this much chaos and
confusion and going off in all
directions I mean this week the
president was all over the issue of gun
control in every different direction he
fired off an order for new tariffs
without even informing the State
Department or his press office he he's
you know he's kind he seemed to be sort
of careening around like a balloon with
the air coming out and yet this is all
happening at a time when the economy is
growing there has been no international
crisis things are relatively calm in the
markets although the Dow of course did
plunge after the announcement of the
steel tariffs but what if there is a
serious international crisis or a
domestic crisis the mayhem in this
administration and this White House is
really worrisome about their capacity to
cope with serious issues so background
on our guest mona Charen she of course
is a syndicated columnist among her
books useful idiots how liberals got it
wrong in the Cold War and still blame
America first she served as an editorial
assistant a National Review speechwriter
for Nancy Reagan also Congressman Jack
Kemp was a commentator on CNN including
capital gang and now a senior fellow at
the ethics and Public Policy Center and
a book coming out in June correct yes
it's called sex matters how modern
feminists got it wrong well that's not
exactly it it's how modern feminists
lost touch with science
and common sense do you come up with
these book titles so I had help on that
one from my dear friend and colleague ed
Whelan the the subtitle was mine but he
came up with the main title sex matters
let's get to your phone calls John is
joining us from Southampton Pennsylvania
Democrats line with Mona chair and good
morning yes good morning um yeah I think
that that Mona arm has no right to
really to attack could totally attack
marine lepen who I think is a great
French Patriot and to hold a nice
responsible for the views of her uncle
you know it's on American and you know
marinas is is for France for the French
as the Israelis were for Israel being
for Jews and I have a question I wonder
how she feels about the forcible
expulsion of 60,000 true war refugees
African War refugees that these real is
apparently there's very little
opposition I'm any European country who
attempted to do what Israel is doing
with this forced expulsion imprisonment
of these true war refugees um I mean it
would be an it wouldn't hear the end of
it yet
the Israelis are slowly proceeding with
this proposition John thank you okay
caller so first of all get your facts
right
I was condemning Marion lepen who was
not the niece of jean-marie Le Pen but
the granddaughter the niece you're
thinking of is marine lepen who ran to
the presidency in France last year so
study up a bit second I think you're an
anti-semite because the first thing you
want to talk with me about is Israel so
I think that that that sort of suggests
where you're coming from you say that
that Marion lepen is for France for the
French if you talk to French people they
will tell you that her brand
France for the French includes
incredibly cozy relationship utin just
for starters let's go to Patrick joining
us from Baltimore
Democrats line good morning good morning
yeah I want to thank uh Mona and all the
other neighbor comforts and the media
and all the Democrats um it's just uh
when he came down the elevator the
escalator I mean I was hooked I mean he
was my guy all the way and it's just I
hope you guys keep it up because that's
one of the main reasons he won the total
I mean this complete unhinged way that
people talk about him and every little
thing they pick apart and attack his
family and and then something everything
some position this may happen and they
may be doing this and perhaps this is
going to happen and it's just so crazed
I mean we couldn't have better the no
way you could have better a publicity to
get him reelected so I really appreciate
it and keep up the good work actually
thank you in the president announcing
his campaign manager this past week as
he prepares for 2020 so let me let me
say that in the collar may be surprised
to hear that I partially agree with him
because I do think that the tone of a
lot of media coverage has been excessive
you know it's if if the president
reaches for a cup with two hands that's
good for a few news cycles on some of
the network's unfortunately we live in a
world where you now have MSNBC and CNN
and some others who are just you know
non-stop from criticism and so forth
some of it justified some of it may be
overdone and then you have Fox Breitbart
and many other sites on the internet and
great talk radio where it's nonstop
adoration and praise and worship even of
the president so we're becoming more and
more polarized it's very very difficult
for people to figure out what the truth
is but it's still our obligation as
citizens to say you know yeah I I agree
MSNBC is sometimes over the top and
their descriptions of Donald Trump
that doesn't mean that I have to check
my rational ability to make judgments in
the closet I can tell
despite the fact that MSNBC may be wrong
sometimes that they weren't wrong about
Roy Moore I mean there was just too much
evidence and you even had the editor of
Breitbart announcing after Roy Moore
lost that he believed the accusers but
that he was he was just running the ball
for the president hoping that by by
sticking up for this child molester Roy
or you know teenager molester Roy Moore
that that he was running interference
for Donald Trump we welcome our
listeners on POTUS channel 124 in Sirius
XM and those watching on the BBC
Parliament Channel he spends washing
journals carried live every Sunday
afternoon on the BBC Paul is joining us
out west in Show Low Arizona
good morning Democrats line good morning
your guest made a comment about Trump's
taxes and and we all agree on that that
he did promise to show them and then her
ad on was well Hillary has kind of some
shady things to our Hillary's taxes for
the last thirty years on record and
isn't the foundation records public and
doesn't the foundation have a very high
rating with every foundation
fact-checker for what I understand about
ninety cents on every dollar goes out
for charity but that doesn't get much
news you just hear these little remarks
about well Hillary's got this shady
finances - I just like an explanation of
what you mean by that
yeah thank you for the comment during
the campaign and I think even before
that I remember contacting the Clinton
Foundation and trying to get records of
you know the forms that they had filed
with various government agencies that
foundations are required to file with
and they were not available and they
were very evasive about getting me this
information
and I noticed that one of the charity I
think it was Charity Navigator I
couldn't say that for sure but I
remember checking with one of the
charity raiding groups and they declined
to rape the Clinton Foundation because
they said they didn't weren't able to
get the right kinds of information at
least that year they were declining to
raid it so now I I'm sticking with this
I think there was a lot of shady stuff
going on with with Hillary and you know
getting contributions to Bill from
people who were involved with you know
having business before the State
Department and I mean there was really a
very very long list of things that were
questionable it's it's a shame that it
came to that in 2016 the two individuals
who were very ethically compromised were
the choices that were before the
American people hope that never happens
again
let's go to Jeju ideas from Scottsville
Virginia independent line good morning
hello
it was probably sometime in 1980 that
corporate profit seekers recognized that
they could access the first enumerated
power of the legislature to borrow money
against the credit of the United States
and they began developing more and more
precise communications platforms to
manipulate the emotion of the electorate
both factions to put us in debt and
destroy the only reserve currency the
modern scientific world will ever
experience the Republic is dying unless
we can determine and overturn Buckley v
Valeo and citizens united the United
States of America will die thank you
thank you for the call I'm not sure
exactly which of those many points to
pick up on I would just say that
yet our debt is a serious problem I
don't think that it's so much connected
to Buckley v Valeo which has to do with
campaign financing and free speech I
will say though that let me pick up on
the reserve currency point I was just
having a conversation with my husband
about this yesterday one of the great
strengths of this country since the
Second World War has been our the
perception that the whole world has of
us of being extremely stable and when
people have a decision to make about do
they hold dollars or do they hold their
own nation's currency as my husband was
putting it they've chosen to hold
dollars basically because they trusted
our country to be stable and reliable
and to eventually pay its bills if
necessary and not to have some sort of
collapse or crazy gyrations of policy
and so forth so our stability has been
one of our great strengths and it is
something to think about that this
president with his highly erratic
governing style and and sort of
shoot-from-the-hip style of tweeting and
so forth
may be undermining confidence in our in
our country's stability in general we'll
go to James next from Cleveland Ohio
you're talking to Mona cheran and you're
phoning in on the Republican line good
morning good morning sir good morning
ma'am you know what the majority of the
mainstream media predicted Trump was
going to get destroyed in a landslide
and they ended up getting that wrong
they ended up with egg all over their
face to say fancy themselves as the
smartest people in the room therefore
they decided to go to war against our
president with pure hatred pure hatred
against his family and it's just been so
over the top it's unbelievable I mean
this is unprecedented in history how
much hatred has been directed towards
this president and I will never trust
the mainstream left-wing media again
they're nothing but skills
the Democratic Party the New York Times
The Washington Post every time they come
up with these propaganda stories it's
always anonymous sources wow what a
coincidence it's always anonymous
sources so I think Trump's doing a great
job and this media will just not shut up
about this phony baloney Russian
collusion story to try and overthrow a
duly elected president on their side
Barack Obama was spying on Trump and
that scandals a thousand times bigger
than Watergate but the left-wing media
won't cover it because their side
got caught playing dirty thank you I
think that collar is a very good
representative of the president's fans
out there and they interpret everything
through particular lens and I understand
I don't share it I don't think that
everything that comes out of the
mainstream media is wrong I don't think
that they make it up I think they're
talking to for example the posts in the
New York Times and others are talking to
real people inside the administration
and they have good sources and you know
they may spin things in a way that's
negative but that doesn't mean that it
isn't true and you know it's to reject
everything sort of in a wholesale way
that you don't get from Fox News or or a
website or a television station that you
agree with I think it's it's too
close-minded just as I think and have
been saying for 30 years that the
liberal side really needs to broaden
their horizons and listen to
conservatives and try to understand our
critiques and try to understand our
point of view
they've been slow to do it but let me
let me give a shout out to the New York
Times for the editorial page the
editorial page of the New York Times
right now is one of the finest sources
of conservative commentary in America
it's amazing to say that but it is
they've got Ross Talbot they have Brett
Stephens Barry Weiss David Brooks they
have a lineup of really really
thoughtful interesting and deep thinkers
on the right at the New York Times I
think it's it's something that I didn't
expect to see even a few short years ago
so people need to get out of their own
bubbles and acknowledge sometimes that
we've made progress you mentioned the
media and I know we saw you Monday
morning on MSNBC's Morning Joe but have
you appeared on the Fox News Channel
they invited you I got one call from the
Fox News Channel and when I phoned back
they didn't return my call so that was
that since President Trump has been
elected have you been on Fox
I have not let's go to Rob in
Strongsville Ohio Democrats line with
motor chair and good morning hi good
morning
I was calling this is such an
interesting call to hear conservatives
come out and start warning us Monday
Morning Quarterback warning us about all
of these things that during the campaign
were brought up by liberals and
Democrats all of these things involving
Trump's shady business dealings him as a
money launderer him not having his taxes
and as his extramarital affairs him is
raping women these were all things
brought up and now to hear conservatives
come out and start Monday Morning
Quarterback warning us about the
detriments of this is kind of comical
and as far as the previous caller James
yeah the media this this is nothing new
here have you ever found Barack Obama's
birth certificate the real one have you
ever found proof that Michelle Obama was
born by silverback gorillas have you
ever / hey we'll stop there so two
callers in a row kind of illustrative of
where we are as a country you know they
they get their news exclusively from
their own ideological compatriots and
they don't see beyond it and you know
the second caller says oh you know Oh
fine Monday morning quarterbacking now
we're hearing from conservatives well
I'm sorry to tell you my friend but some
of us conservatives have been saying
this all along not a secret lots of us
were out there saying these things it's
not new and if you were to get out of
your
level every now and then and maybe have
a glance at a conservative website you
would you would know that and same with
the caller who preceded him you know
just the people are got blinders on
ideological blinders this polarization
is so awful and it isn't really
I mean it's so out of proportion to our
problems as a country really I mean
weird believe it or not we're in pretty
good shape you know we have problems
everybody has problems we could solve
them if we were interested in solving
them but right now I think we're not I
think we're really enjoying this bitter
nasty vitriolic partisan sniping and and
hatred at one another we're marinating
in hatred and I don't think any good can
come from that
Senator Jeff Flake of Arizona is going
to be in New Hampshire later this month
and Ohio Governor John Kasich in early
April do you think the president will
face a primary challenge in 2020 very
possible very possible from Yukon
Oklahoma on the Republican line Bonnie
good morning hello I would like to say
that I'll tell all these people were
like in plan trumps choices they are
under all of Obama's records it's to
record his birth certificate
and all that stuff is he son Obama jump
that he did you find Trump taxes and I
used to be a Democrat no more thank you
Bonnie thank you we'll go on to Mike in
Modesto California Democrats line with
Moana cheering good morning all right I
seem like us Democrats we sort of think
if you just do the right thing and
explain things right and things will
just work out and Republicans are like
you know whatever it takes we're going
to do it so the nature of this election
you know the three million votes the one
way and the 80,000 votes squeezed in and
all of a sudden he acts like 80% of the
country was on his side and he nominates
all these people with mentalities from
from the 70 60 70 South you know Jeff
Sessions and the EPA guide you know give
shut that down and so on but that was I
would like to know can you imagine the
right-wingers especially how if the
situation were reversed and there were
cysts and he got this big a popular vote
and she just squeezed in like that can
you imagine the loving cooperation and I
would say about this all these uh all
the Republicans who just slammed him
non-stop as you know he'd be in whatever
I was looking to say about him if you're
honest and now that where they line up
to take turns praising him can only be
because their posters show them that if
you a camp in this just you might lose
so the only thing they care about
getting reelected so there you are
that's what they're going to do and it's
it's sad but anyway that bless you all
Mike thank you from California I would
just say that you know look there's no
there's no denying that lots of
Republicans have fallen into line and
are now sort of praising the president
and they are highly aware that he is
very popular with their base and so
they're reluctant to reluctant to
criticize him but that's certainly true
I would not endorse completely the
caller's view that Democrats are always
for doing you know what's right and
moving forward and Republicans are the
ones who will just use any tactic I mean
just just to take one example the the
last president the Democratic president
floated the law by just issuing
executive orders even when he said
himself that he wasn't a dictator that
he didn't have the power to change the
law unilaterally that it would require
an act of Congress and so forth he said
this over and over and then he went
ahead and did it so you know there's
very often an attitude
on both sides but I found it
particularly true of the Democrats in
recent years that you know the
procedures and and tradition and law be
damned we want to get our outcomes and
however we can get them we'll do it
whether it's through executive orders or
whether it's through using the courts or
whether it's through you know some other
method they they just want the outcome
and they're less concerned about the
process and I think we all have to be
concerned about process because that's
what makes us free that's the the rule
of law is the the highest priority we'll
go to de Soto Kansas next Diane good
morning Republican line with Mona Sharon
syndicated columnist she's also a senior
fellow at the ethics and Policy Center
good morning Diane good morning Steven
good morning Mona the reason for my call
is twofold I am a Republican and I voted
for a president Trump because I believe
that our country was headed too far in
the left direction and I put that aside
or I put that before I put his his
tweets and things of that nature that
seem to concern some people and I think
I'm like a lot of people in that regard
the second thing I would like to ask you
ma'am is if you are so concerned about
Donald Trump's sexual indiscretions
quote-unquote I would ask you does that
mean that we should not have had
President Roosevelt President Kennedy
President Clinton President Eisenhower
how many others are there these things
are going to happen and as long as we
live they will continue to happen and I
would like your you're thinking about
that please thank you
sure well first of all the it's it's
kind of a shocking thing to see the
Republican Party which claimed the
character counted when Bill Clinton was
president and that these things are
important for setting a standard about
public conduct have now flipped
completely and say oh well you know it's
not important whether you have personal
integrity and character about your
sexual behavior so that's that's ironic
and and I have to say that that in the
case of the president sadly his behavior
toward women is only one symptom of very
bad character in many other respects as
well and I have been much more worried
about some of things that he has done as
president that you know are also signs
of character but for example the pardon
of Joe Arpaio the the endorsement as I
said of Roy Moore the comments after
Charlottesville you know there's a
there's a sort of comprehensive bullying
tone an embrace of of strong men and
authoritarians there's this tone that he
takes that I find antithetical to what
we conservatives believe we are sort of
small-l liberals in the sense if we
believe in the world of law we believe
in tradition decorum decency to see this
president not leave aside the sexual
stuff to see him praising dictators and
strongmen around the world to see him
saying to a thug like duterte who was
the president of Philippines and is
murdering you know extrajudicial
killings have become the norm in
Philippines under the sky and telling
that praising him and saying you're
doing a great job again you know with
the drug problem those are really really
worrisome and very anti-democratic
against MALDI sentiments and instincts
that this president has so it goes far
beyond mere sexual misconduct though I
don't think that sexual misconduct on
the scale that he has done it is this is
a is a trivial matter either it's a sign
of bad character I want to follow up on
that point
with Jonathan Tobit of national review
but first jill has been waiting from
Kingston New York independent line good
morning good morning and thank you for
having me I just wanted to mention that
all of the calls that have been going on
this morning have been really a very
good example of the diversity that has
happened and the device of this that has
happened in this country and I wouldn't
say it's just because of Trump he just
epitomizes the peak that we are at now
it's been happening for decades and it's
been happening with a lot a lot of
different politicians and and also
things that had been put in place one
caller mentioned citizens united that
was you know a very powerful force that
has changed the political system in this
country that was a very good excuse me
very good example of how things have
changed in this country and
unfortunately people are not looking at
the historical properties that are being
set in place from when basically you had
fascism under Hitler and when Hitler did
certain things - he was he was voted in
he was voted into office and when he was
a voted into office he found somebody to
blame for the way that the country was
going Joe thank you for the call well we
it's true it didn't start with Trump one
reform that I've maybe a little
frivolous leoben's been floating that we
need is all comments sections on all
websites and newspapers and all the rest
of it should require that people
identify themselves the the anonymity of
the Internet has created the cesspool
where abuse and vitriol is just spewed
out because people aren't identified and
big and they can treat
you know it's somebody who writes
something or says something as non-human
and and so we our politics unfortunately
has begun to resemble the comments
section and you're right it didn't start
with Trump though he's arguably made it
worse because he's president but but I
don't I'm sorry you're the second caller
has mentioned citizens united in this
context and I just don't think that that
is is relevant to the the degradation of
our public discourse two final points
first I mentioned jonathan Tobin of
National Review and and you refer to
this earlier but he wrote it is almost
impossible to separate Donald Trump the
man and the social media creature from
Trump the president but conservatives
must try to do so because Trump's
presidency has seen a series of major
conservative victories right so I hear
this a lot from my conservative friends
and they say you know aren't you happy
about the deregulatory agenda and you
know certain moves on defense and some
other things and the tax cuts and my
reply is I'm at Gorsuch I'm happy about
many things this administration has done
but the question is not has he done good
things there have been good things that
have happened it's at what price and I
think we are paying the the conservative
movement the Republican Party is going
to pay a terrible price for embracing
Donald Trump that if you look at the way
he and conservatism and Republicans are
viewed by voters under the age of 40
it's a disaster and especially women
minorities young people it's we are we
are suffering reputational damage that
may be irreparable final point this is a
headline from Daily Beast president
Trump jokes that Melania might leave him
at the gridiron dinner in reason part
president Trump excusing his late
arrival by suggesting that Jaron cook
Jared Kushner could not get through
security
he said he offered the Attorney General
Jeff Sessions a ride to the
but he quote recused himself I would not
rule out talks with Kim jong-un he told
the crowd according to axis calm as far
as risks are talking to a madman that's
his concern not mine and he combined an
attack on CNN with a shot at his former
chief adviser saying quote it's been a
tough year for CNN and they've lost a
tremendous amount of credibility this
year and your best reporter Steve Bannon
that guy leaked more than that Titanic
boy did he leak so many people have been
leaving the White House he went on to
say it is invigorating since you want
turnover I like chaos it really is good
he said who's going to be the next to
leave Steve Miller or Melania and then
he concluded by saying he thanked the
media for their attendance he supports
the support and sustain our democracy
adding I mean that the Gridiron Club
dinner last night your thoughts good
fine you know he's having he's having a
little fun I suppose and he's even kind
of funny good for him
mouna cheering thanks very much for
being with us come back often thank you